That brings us to a discussion of procedural
design versus an object-based design. You're all familiar,
I'm sure, with procedural design where you're writing
your code as one monolithic entity, and in a
procedural world, you have shared state in terms
of global variables, and you may have private
state in the caller and the callee. And
state is now distributed all over the place. So,
basically, the interface between the caller and the
callee is through the normal procedure call mechanism that
one sub-system may make a procedure call that
goes into another subsystem. And this is how monolithic
kernels are built where state is now strewn
all over the place. There maybe some shared state
and private state of subsystems and so on,
and this is typically how monolithic systems are built.
To contrast this procedural design to object-based
design, in an object-based design, objects contain the
state that is entirely contained within this
object, not visible outside. And there are methods
that are inside those object that manipulate
the state that is part of this object.
So in other words, externally, the state is
not visible. The only thing that is visible
are the methods for invocation and these invocations
work on the state that is local to the
object. So what you get with an object-based
design is strong interfaces and complete isolation of the
state of an object from everything else. Contrast
that with the procedural design, where the state can
be strewn all over the place, and the
shared state can be manipulated from several different subsystems
that are part of a big monolith. But in this case, what we have is, strong
interfaces that completely separate one object from other
objects. And the state that is specific to
an object is contained entirely inside this object,
invisible to other objects outside except via well-defined
invocation methods. That have been exposed by this
object implementor to the outside world. As OS designers,
the immediate question that might come up is,
well, if we have these strong interfaces, it sounds
similar to what we discussed when we talked about
the structure of operating systems early on, and that
is border corssing across protection domains. Is it going to
cost us? But, there are ways around it. To
make these border crossing performance conscious as well. Now,
where to apply this object orientation? Well, in Spring,
for instance, they applied object orientation in building
the operating system kernel. So the key point
to take away is, if object orientation is
good at the level of implementing a high performance
operating system kernel, it should be good at
higher levels of the software as well. And while
I am expounding the virtues of object-based design
here, we have already seen this when we talked
about Tornado system. That was also using
an object-based approach to building operating system kernels.